you may never have heard of Kenema
Sierra Leone or ruin Nigeria but I know
them as two of the most extraordinary
places on earth in hospitals there
there's a community of nurses physicians
and scientists that have been quietly
battling one of the deadliest threats to
humanity for years
loss of iris Lassa virus is a lot like
Ebola
it can cause a severe fever and can
often be fatal but these individuals
they risk their lives every day to
protect the individuals in their
communities and by doing so protect us
all but one of the most extraordinary
things I learned about them on one of my
first visits out there many years ago
was that they start each morning these
challenging extraordinary days on the
front lines by singing they gather
together and they show their joy they
show their spirit and over the years
from year after year as I visited them
and they visited me I get to gather with
them and I sing and we write and we love
it because it reminds us that we're not
just there to pursue science together
were bonded through a shared humanity
and that of course as you can imagine
becomes extremely important even
essential as things begin to change and
that changed a great deal in March of
2014 when the Ebola outbreak was
declared in Guinea this is the first
outbreak in West Africa near the border
of Sierra Leone and Liberia and it was
frightening frightening for us all we
actually suspected for some time that
Lhasa and Ebola were more widespread
than thought and we thought it could one
day come to Kenema and so members of my
team immediately went out and joined dr.
umar khan and his team there we set up
Diagnostics to be able to have sensitive
molecular tests to pick up Ebola if it
came across the border and into Sierra
Leone we'd already set up this kind of
pasty for lots of virus we knew how to
do it the team is outstanding we just
had to give them the tools in place to
survey for Ebola and
fortunately that day came on May 23rd
2014 a woman checked into the maternity
ward at the hospital and the team ran
those important molecular tests and they
identified the first confirmed case of
Ebola and Sierra Leone this was an
exceptional work that was done they were
able to diagnose the case immediately to
safely treat the patient and to begin to
do contact tracing to follow what was
going on it could have stopped something
but by the time that day came the
outbreak had already been breeding for
months with hundreds of cases it had
already clipped all previous outbreaks
and it came in - Sierra Leone not as
that singular case but as a tidal wave
we had to work with the international
community with the Ministry of Health
with Kenema to begin to deal with the
cases as the next week about 31 the 92
then 147 cases all coming to Kenema one
of the only places in Sierra Leone that
could deal with this and we worked
around the clock trying to do everything
we could
trying to help the individuals trying to
get attention we also did one other
simple thing from that specimen that we
take from a patient's blood to detect
Ebola we you know we can discard it
obviously the other thing we can do is
actually we can put in a chemical and
deactivate it - just a simple place it
into a box and ship it across the ocean
and that's what we did we sent it to
Boston where my team works and we also
worked around the clock doing shift work
day after day and we quickly generated
99 genomes of the Ebola virus this is
the blueprint the genome of the virus is
a blueprint we all have one it says
everything that makes up us and it tells
us so much information the results of
this kind of work are simple and they're
powerful we could actually take these 99
different viruses look at them and
compare them we could see actually
compared to three genomes that had been
previously published from Guinea we
could show that the outbreak emerged in
Guinea months before once into the human
population and from there have been
transmitting from human to human that's
incredibly important when you're trying
to figure out how to intervene that the
important thing is contact tracing we
also could see that as the virus was
moving between humans it was mutating
and each of those mutations are so
important because the Diagnostics the
vaccines
the therapies that we're using are all
based on that genome sequence
fundamentally that's what drives it and
so global health experts would need to
respond would have to develop to
recalibrate everything that they were
doing but the way that science works the
position that I was in at that point is
I had the data and I could have worked
in a silo for many many months analyze
the data carefully slowly submitted the
paper for publication gone through a few
back and forth and then finally when the
paper came out might release that data
that's the way the status quo works well
that was not gonna work at this point
right we had friends on the front lines
and to us it was just obvious that what
we needed is help lots of help so the
first thing we did is as soon as the
sequences came off the machines we
published it to the web we just released
it to the whole world and said help us
and help came before we knew it we were
being contacted from people all over
sort of surprised to see the data out
there and released some of the greatest
viral trackers in the world were
suddenly part of our community we were
working together in this virtual way
sharing regularly calls communications
trying to follow the virus minute by
minute to see ways that we could stop it
and there are so many ways that we can
form communities like that right
everybody particularly when the outbreak
started to expand globally was reaching
out to learn to participate to engage
right everybody wants to play a part the
amount of human capacity out there is
just amazing and the internet connects
us all and could you imagine that
instead of being fined of each other
that we all just said let's do this
let's work together and let's make this
happen but the problem is that the data
that all of us are using googling on the
web is just too limited to do what we
need to do and so many opportunities get
missed when that happens so in the early
part of the epidemic from Kenema we had
106 clinical records from patients and
we once again made that publicly
available to the world in our own lab we
could show that you could take those 106
records we could train computers to
predict the prognosis for Ebola patients
to near 100% accuracy and we made an app
that could release that to make that
available to healthcare workers in the
field but 106 is just not enough right
to make it powerful to validate it
so we are waiting for more data to
release that and the data has still not
come we are still waiting
tweaking away in silos rather than
working together and this just we can't
accept that are you all of you cannot
accept that it's our lives on the lines
and in fact actually many lives were
lost many healthcare workers including
beloved colleagues of mine five
colleagues ba Lu phony Alex Moog boy
Doctor Who mark on Alice Cove Allah and
Mohammed fula these are just five of
many health care workers at Kenema and
beyond that died while the world waited
and while we all worked quietly and
separately see Ebola like all threats to
humanity it's fueled by mistrust and
distraction and division when we build
barriers amongst ourselves we fight
amongst ourselves
the virus thrives but unlike all sets to
humanity a bolus one were actually all
the same we're all in this fight
together Ebola on one person's doorstep
could soon be on ours and so in this
place with the same vulnerabilities the
same strengths the same fears the same
hopes I hope that we work together with
joy a graduated student of mine was
reading a book about Sierra Leone she
discovered that the word Kenema the
hospital that we work at the city where
we work in Sierra Leone is named after
the Mende word for clear like a river
translucent and open to the public gaze
and that was really profound for us
because without knowing it we'd always
felt that in order to honor the
individuals in Kenema where we worked we
had to work openly we had to share and
we had to work together and we have to
do that we all have to demand that of
ourselves and others to be open to each
other when an outbreak happens to fight
in this fight together because this is
not the first outbreak of Ebola it will
not be the last and there are many other
microbes out there that are lying in
wait like Lassa virus and others and the
next time this happens it could happen
in a city of millions start there it
could be something that's transmitted
through the air it could even be
disseminated intentionally and so I know
that that is frightening I understand
that but I know also and this experience
shows us that we have
the technology and we have the capacity
to win this thing to win this and have
the upper hand over viruses but we can
only do it if we do it together and we
do it with joy
so for dr. Khan and for all of those who
sacrifice their lives on the frontlines
in this fight with us always let us be
in this fight with them always and let
us not let the world be defined by the
destruction wrought by one virus but
illuminated by billions of hearts and
minds working in unity thank you